bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi andiamo avanti con cat mario per la
mia gioia
prima di iniziare la gabbo levo
ringraziarvi per il traguardo raggiunto
15.000 iscritti ragazzi veramente non ho
parole 15mila sono veramente un
traguardo incredibile però non voglio
parlando in questo video perché
ovviamente farò un video speciale anche
per i 15mila e uscirà appunto sabato
quindi vi dico solo che è il video più
idiota che io abbia mai fatto cioè
aspettatevi di tutto uscire appunto
sabato è dato continuamente non ho fatto
praticamente quasi nulla di giochi oro
alla parte penombra vi annuncio che sta
per iniziare a punto la nuova serie
horror dovrebbe iniziare se tutto va
bene domani
e inoltre ho intenzione di portare
avanti tantissimi altri in di horror che
mi state consigliando da secoli quindi
tranquilli che anche con loro si rinizia
detto questo direi di proseguire col
nostro amatissimo gioco cat mario
eravamo rimasti ovviamente adesso non mi
ricordo nemmeno io dov'ero rimasto però
madonna ma sono quattro giorni che non
lo tocco è già partiamo bene allora me
lo sento stavolta mi sento più carico
eravamo rimasti che praticamente dovevo
prendere un punto interrogativo che
faceva salto che cazzo non mi ricordo le
cose partiamo di merda
va beh facciamo finta di niente eravamo
rimasti che praticamente vo preso un
punto interrogativo che mi aveva fatto
morire dovevo prendere non dovevo
prendere un punto interrogativo scusate
visto confondendo che è praticamente
faceva esplodere una specie di tubo
vulcano non so anche che cazzo era è e
io c'ero cascato in pieno praticamente
non siamo per incontrare se questo qui
alla praticamente devo saltare st fare
ok che c'è l'ultima volta mi ha [ __ ]
è ero rimasto qui praticamente o che ci
sono allora piano è un po difficile loro
andiamo avanti andiamo indietro
ok allora vediamo di essere più vicino
no no no no ma cazzo ci credo madonna
modonna madonna ma john allora iniziamo
di merda sto terzo episodio non vedo
l'ora di finire sto cazzo di gioco di
merda ok allora piano dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai set
se ce l'ha fatta che culo allora ok no
ma che cazzo ma quattro soli di ota ma
[ __ ]
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo adesso calmi
calmissimi devo fare sto [ __ ] punto
di merda non posso bloccarmi qui allora
ok mi sento che la volta buona si no
oddio guardate ha fatto sono rimasto
cazzo qui me la sono vista bruttissima
allora c'è un'attenzione addosso che non
avete idea allora piano piano
andiamo avanti ok ok ok no ma cazzo
no no no no non ci credo
ok ce l'ho fatta mira cosa mente adesso
ci riprovo
ok adesso cosa devo fare
non lo so allora devo arrivare al tubo
ok allora prova a fare così
dai dai non ci posso credere
siamo al terzo livello fa chi è
non ci credo devo andare ovvio che cos'è
è un pezzo è un peto fantasma gli sa che
sta roba la devo saltare come l'altra
volta ok perfetto oddio oddio cazzo mi
ha superato la bandiera praticamente
avevo in mente di saltarci sopra tipo
così perfetto adesso devo andare avanti
si nomi fatti più non entrati dentro so
che è una trappola
ce l'ho fatta
se che culo che culo ma dai è culo
assurdo che non ci
no perché sono morto no non sono morto
era un troll ce l'ho fatta perfetto
ragazzi siamo quarto livello non so
neanche che cosa devo fare qui c'è un
fiore che ha preso ma io non devo
prendere me lo prendo lo stesso e sono
morto conclusione sono un cazzo di
idiota c'è nulla le stelle che stuprano
nomi hanno preso ce l'ho fatta allora
devo riuscire a saltare su stappare
perfetto ce l'ho fatta
fuck you be there iniziare da qui porca
[ __ ] prima che ci riesco di nuovo
ok perfetto come non detto ce l'ho fatta
ebbene allora posso andare avanti lo
stesso se allora devo saltare sta merda
perché ok no no no kat
per ora devo diventare campione di salto
in lungo perfetto c'è la forza se no no
ma cazzo ma ce la posso addio
c'è un'altra bandiera fuori j finalmente
la mia salvezza
c'è allora un punto interrogativo perché
c'è una linea di parcheggio
devo prenderla
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo perfetto
ok no lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
stavolta ci sono allora saltiamo più
avanti prendiamo la bandiera grazie dio
grazie grazie infinite c'è veramente
ragazzi quando quando finisce sta roba
c'era veramente non ne posso più devo
andare di sotto non dovevo andare lì
sotto non dovevo andare di sotto e cosa
ho fatto io cosa ho fatto
sono andato 18 [ __ ] allora piano
c'è da fare che si è buttato giù e mi
butto giù anch'io
cos'è cos'è quella roba devo saltare da
questo punto perché sono un cadeau
perfetto adesso mi spiegate chi è questo
c'è la losco e più epico del peso
fantasma raga vabbè allora andiamo a
devo saltare su quelle rocce ovviamente
credete che non ci sia una trappola non
c'era effettivamente non era una
trappola non ci crea per una volta che
pensavo ci fosse una trappola non c'era
ok
beh no ma katz c'è ma mi state prendendo
per il culo sta a fare salda f addio no
ma perché ma perché ma perché lo vedi il
dito o seguì il dito seguì il dito
seguito bravissimo
andiamo avanti c'è la bandiera fa vj c'è
il trappolino di scrivere nostri
guardate a destra
ok devo riuscire a raggiungerla saltando
così perché non sto facendo niente sta
saltando la solo solo che è un po un
casino non ci provo ce l'ho fatta non ci
posso credere alloggio e trampolino che
spero sia come quello di scribe loud che
mi spara ai fatti lo sapevo il caso è
quello sembra tipo superman fantasma
ok perfetto sono morto non dovevo
neanche fare così devo probabilmente
andare qui sopra e poi la so perche i no
no no no no ok si no fecero quasi almeno
capito come si fa
ragazze ma almeno 99 ci sono ragazzi
sono ci sono sei perfetto bene devo dare
i soldi che culo
vabbè mi sono salvato per miracolo che
cosa sto facendo ha buttato la bandiera
perfetto
ora forse si riesca a passare senza che
torni indietro se entra entra brutto
stronzo
come si fa ad entrare
non si può non devo entrare soltanto con
la barba affanculo devo entrare con la
bandiera come faccia entrare con la
bandiera se c'è quella fare me lo dovete
spiegare come faccio ad entrare non so
come ho fatto a salvarmi perché mi stavo
suicidando
non so come è come diavolo ok forse ho
capito ho capito
credo di aver capito non ho capito
[Musica]
no
sì cazzo non ci posso credere
ci ho messo due ore [ __ ] gatto di
merda ci ho messo veramente due ore
non ci posso veramente credere che cazzo
cos'è sta roba adesso non ho veramente
c'era che io veramente non ci ho parole
è una cosa veramente fuori dal mondo sto
gioco cioè fatto proprio per farti
esasperare al limite c'è impossibile c'è
veramente raga io voglio chiuderla qui
per questo episodio sono due ore che ho
provato quella fare e che cazzo ho fatto
come ho fatto a salvarmi è vasto punto
continuo finché non muoiono tanto morire
subito perfetto
adesso magari finivo il gioco vabbè
comunque direi che posso chiudere qui
perché veramente stato esasperante se vi
è piaciuto il video come al solito raga
mi dimentico il telecomando in fondo a
tutta la roba comunque se vi è piaciuto
il video come al solito lasciato un
commento vi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come al solito trovate
nella descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi e noi
ci vediamo al prossimo video bella
ragazzi